on est à la place des arts en ce moment
c'est sûr qu'on le voit pas trop parce
que les écrans cachent les sièges on est
vraiment à la salle wilfrid pelletier
l'humoriste rachid badouri n'a que de
bons mots pour l'espace [ __ ] une
plateforme de diffusion de spectacles ou
à distance
les spectateurs peuvent interagir grâce
à dix caméras et six écrans géants et
peut voir là il peut voir lors à narnia
et un écran qui suit de dos pour voir un
peu ce que ça donne comme écran ce que
j'ai de la sauce end tandis que les
rassemblements de plus de 50 personnes
sont toujours interdits cet espace
virtuel peut accueillir des milliers de
personnes par la magie d'internet on
parce que c'est une belle alternative
pour pouvoir présenter du spectacle le
coût de la location de l'espace [ __ ]
varie de 3500 à 12000 dollars selon la
grosseur du projet ajoutez à cela des
frais de près de 5 dollars par
spectateur pour payer la bande passante
c'est pas quelque chose ou on va faire
des profits très franchement mon
objectif c'est de faire un break even
autant de la pandémie les spectacles
virtuels ont la cote
la plateforme live thoune existe depuis
2012 et récemment la demande est forte
allez phénoménal en depuis trois mois on
a new x de nos équipes
et je pense que à partir du mois d'août
ça va être encore en vain multiplié par
3 parce qu'on n'a pas le choix
le modèle d'affaires de l'iphone
n'exclut pas la participation du public
est à 3000 $ la captation on voit des
profits à l'horizon le streaming vidéo
la captation et la billetterie wyss ça
va ça va être rentable
peut-être pas sur le court terme je
pense qu'avec des méthodes de production
totalement différente et innovante
on est capable de produire à moindre
coût autant de la pandémie le virtuel
est un outil essentiel me rachète
badouri a bien hâte de voir la suite
moi je souhaite pas que ça soit l'avenir
parce que ça voudrait dire que l'avenir
est en confinement et je voudrais pas
que ça arrive j'ai vraiment trop hâte de
revoir du monde du vivant moi je suis je
dois absolument voir ces gens là ici
louis fait depuis mai radio-canada m'ont
rien